hi i'm catherine and i like capitalism
a lot
but in my 20 years as a libertarian
journalist i have started to pick up
that some people aren't as fond of
capitalism as i am
that's fine but here's the thing i think
a lot of the stuff that you think you
hate about capitalism
is actually stuff to hate about
government
before we get started kvetching though i
want to sing you a little song and
you've probably heard it before so feel
free to sing along if you like don't
worry i'm not actually going to sing
it's fine
200 years ago in 1820
the global rate of absolute poverty
which is defined imperfectly is living
on less than 1.90 a day was 84
that's enormous today the world bank
puts that number at 9
over the same period
life expectancy went from less than 30
years to 72 and there were similarly
remarkable gains in access to food water
housing education during that period
that period coincides so neatly with the
rise of global capitalism that i flatly
refuse to believe it's a coincidence
i think sometimes we get so caught up in
talking about what capitalism could or
should be
that we forget what it has been and what
it is so i want to just take a minute to
do some like greatest hits of capitalism
they include
electric light
personal mobile phones
cheap fertilizer
commercial aviation and current
capitalists are working on cool stuff
like
cryptocurrencies and
geoengineering
and
plant-based meat
i also recently learned that there is a
zero sugar alcoholic version of taco
bell's baja blast mountain dew
and i don't actually know if that's a
point for or against my argument but it
did really feel like you should know
so amongst all of this miraculous market
activity we also have government and
that means we have two problems
the first problem is that governments
don't love it when weird new stuff gets
born
second problem is that governments also
don't love it when familiar old stuff
dies
so let's talk about the new stuff first
the thing about capitalism is that it is
an emergent system it's uh
like all evolutionary mechanisms
powered by
mutations
and
in this case what the mutations are are
very weird people
trying new stuff and when we need
really big progress big new stuff that
means we need really really weird people
elon
looking at you buddy i don't know where
you are today
prior to the rise of modern capitalism
it absolutely sucked to be weird
uh best case scenario a new idea ended
up kind of dying on the vine for lack of
opportunities or resources to go forward
worst case scenario trying something
heroic and new could put you at odds
with the powers that be in times and
places when those powers were absolute
so imagine you have a great plan to open
up a new trade route between europe and
asia during the anglo-dutch wars that is
a brilliant way to get a face full of
cannonballs
i'm not saying that every weirdo has a
brilliant apocalypse averting idea that
also happens to be a viable commercial
enterprise
most new ideas are bad
there's a reason people haven't done it
before
just like most mutations are
evolutionary dead ends
but that's okay
because
high functioning capitalism is
characterized by a tremendous amount of
corporate failure
governments don't actually like it when
familiar old corporations fail they
prefer to do business with the
taxable already regulated devils that
they know
but that's too bad because my personal
favorite thing about companies is that
they can die
when companies die of course that
imposes
hardship on customers on employees on
communities on your 401k
my family wasn't allowed to set foot in
a walmart for a generation after walmart
put my granddaddy's general store out of
business so i get it
at the same time failure is the fate of
nearly every company
and that is why capitalism works
imagine if you will when a company fails
it releases into the market labor and
resources talent that can be better used
elsewhere imagine a tree falling in the
forest and rotting and fueling new
growth
good news though for fans of corporate
death like myself
the original fortune 500 list in 1955
of the companies on that list only 52
are still on the list that means 90
of those companies either went under or
merged or
just fell off the list altogether and
corporate death does seem to be
accelerating
the lifespan of a company on the s p 500
was 61 years in the late 50s today it's
less than 18.
to better understand this corporate
birth and death dynamic i'm going to
tell you two
wildly oversimplified stories
the first is about general motors and
the second is about facebook now i
didn't pick these companies because i
think they are particularly evil or even
terribly unusual they're doing stuff
that makes sense in a system that's
a little bit broken
so let's start by talking about general
motors
general motors is actually one of the
tiny number of companies from that
original fortune 500 list in 1955 that's
still
hanging out near the top
and
starting a car company is moderately
nuts really at any time it's a pretty
impressive thing that they took
what was once
a ridiculous luxury and turned it into
an everyday necessity but then
government got used to gm gm got used to
governments and by 1981
government
is
using the power of eminent domain to
wipe out an entire working-class
neighborhood in detroit
just because gm wants to build a factory
there that cuddling continues through
the 2008 financial crisis when gm
received
really quite a massive bailout from the
government
that's not market failure that's
government failure market would have
stripped gm for parts a long time ago
now let's talk about facebook
same deal right sort of wacky people
trying something new just to see if
it'll work and at first facebook was fun
remember we got hot dates and we found
lost dogs and college reunions became
totally obsolete which was awesome
a few people made a lot of money and the
rest of us were a little bit better off
but flash forward 14 or 15 years and
facebook is being called repeatedly to
the congressional carpet to answer for
actually all the sins of big tech
mark zuckerberg though takes a
conciliatory stance he asks only to be
allowed to help write the regulations
that will govern his firm and
coincidentally those of his
competitors
here's where it gets a little
complicated though because even as some
legislators
are working with facebook lobbyists to
write rules for the industry others have
introduced a bill to
break up facebook and punish it for its
sheer
size
meanwhile an informal poll of the gen
zier's in my life informs me that
facebook is cringe
tic tac is eating facebook's lunch and
uh the first quarter earnings report of
meta came with a surprise
the market cap of the firm had actually
dropped below the level written into
that bill to fund it to punish firms for
being too big
so the jokes on congress facebook is
going to end up avoiding regulation by
shrinking
but unfortunately it's going to take its
competitors with it
this is a classic example of politicians
being lagging
not leading indicators
we are rich thanks to two centuries of
global capitalism but we do still have
problems as a great sage once observed
mo money may in fact correlate with mo
problems
the way forward is to figure out what
the public and private sector can each
do best and help them figure out how to
stay in their lane when it comes to
government i am open to the possibility
that the answer to what it can do best
is
nothing
but we don't all have to become
anarchists today it's clear that
liberal institutions rule of law
functioning courts private property
rights have been very powerful in this
project of fostering innovation
you already know what markets do best
they let people
try stuff they send strong signals when
that stuff isn't working and they have
fueled an incredible
arc of growth and poverty eradication
if we are to have optimism for a
radically better world to continue this
path that capitalism has put us on we
cannot let government collaborate with
business to wreck the engine of the
market
weirdos trying stuff and sometimes being
allowed to fail at it are our best hope
as a species thank you